what's up guys
bang bang it is lunch money time while
while she's trying to get rich dresses
trying to get our lunch money right
i'm here with the beautiful intelligent
pelina evilova marinova pompliano
p-i-m-p
don't forget that lunch money is now
sponsored by block five
go get a block fly account block five
dot com slash pomp
again block five dot com slash pomp go
get a blackfy account bang bang
cool first up the trump administration
proposed a 916
billion dollar coronavirus relief
package on tuesday
after congressional democrats shot down
a suggestion for a pair down plan
from the senate's leading republican
mitch mcconnell
wow another trillion dollars in stimulus
how do we feel print it
it's not going to get passed wait why i
highly highly doubt it's going to get
passed
because democrats they wanna you know
2.2 trillion
the trump administration proposed that
yeah the republicans
yeah and the democrats are going to say
no they want more no i think they're
kind of satisfied
do they say so well pelosi and schumer
said in a statement it was progress that
mcconnell had signed off on a 916
billion dollar offer
but bipartisan talks were the best hope
for a solution
yeah and then they say that hey he cut
the unemployment insurance proposal
uh that's already being discussed and
that's unacceptable so
i mean what's the difference between
friends between
no a trillion here a trillion there who
cares right uh
look this is absolute insanity the first
thing that should happen is you open up
the economy you'll immediately release a
lot of pressure the second thing that
you should do is you should say hey
if you're old if you're pre-existing
conditions or you're scared to go
outside
let us know and then what you do is you
figure out who needs help
but the reason why they're arguing over
how much money to give people who don't
have jobs
is because they don't have jobs and if
you want to fix the unemployment problem
stop trying to give people money
instead what you should do is open up
the economy so people can go back to
work
it is kind of like a pressure cooker
like when you release some of the
pressure
but you're right in that they could
release pressure by
letting people go back to their jobs
although a lot of those jobs don't exist
anymore
and guess what more and more of those
jobs are going away
every day that they don't have the
economy 10 000 restaurant jobs will
disappear in the next few weeks
according to
the national restaurant association it
is insane
it is insane that during the summer
it was okay to have outdoor dining there
was no problem there was no issue
with covet and now all of a sudden
outdoor dining is being banned in places
this isn't about science this isn't
about a virus
this is all about idiots in power
trying to exert their control it is kind
of interesting now that like
politicians are celebrities in a way
have you noticed that
it's like they're ever they're on tv
they're on social media we're talking
about what so-and-so said like i don't
give up
anyway again again literally
if you want to have a large gathering of
people outside
if you say i'm going to serve them food
you're not allowed to do that
but if you say we're protesting you can
do that and again
i love the fact that in america you can
protest go outside and protest your ass
off
right whatever your cause is get loud
it's just get outside it's just
but also open up the restaurant so
people can sit outside and eat food it's
just not uniform
yeah of course and in la la's the the
funniest example of all of them they
literally tried to mandate
everything's got to shut down
restaurants all this stuff except for
you can't go outside and walk but you
can go play
golf or pickleball what is pickleball
what is the pickleball association doing
lobbying for approval and a carve out
for pickleball we should get the
pickleball people here in new york like
i
i'm all about no it's just lobby give me
a break
give me a break that we literally have
legislation being passed where it is
banned to go outside for a walk but you
if you play golf
or pickleball it's okay wake up
all right this is absurd ready yes
pissed off about this nonsense go ahead
she's not really mad but
doordash the food delivery provider uh
sold shares and it's ipo 102 a piece
pricing way above its range
the offering on tuesday values the
company at 32.4 billion
based on common stock outstanding and
38.7 billion on a fully diluted basis
this makes tony the ceo a billionaire
on paper i love it i love it bang bang
good for him cool you know why because
in america
we have capitalism and in capitalist
societies when you build
things of value that give people jobs
you get to make money
it's beautiful show me the incentives
and i'll show you the outcome guys
look at this awesome company watch the
documentary
the donut king and you will see how
uh communist cambodia what happened
there
and and how this man came to the united
states as a refugee
and became a multi-millionaire and he
was so proud and then he gambled it
all away but he was so good at
building it and he built it twice he
became rich
in america twice lost it all came back
okay
um uber let's do it i don't know what
they're doing they're selling all their
moon shots
so uh uber sold its air taxi business
elevate
uh to joby innovation shedding its last
moonshot you know after you did the the
the robo taxi or the whatever so
yeah uber's investing 75 million into
joby and
expanding the uh what is it
basically they're selling their air taxi
business
i had never seen an air taxi i don't
know about you guys but i didn't know
they had that so
they must have some technology or
licenses or something that these other
guys want
because uh i never seen the air attacks
i've never been in one well but
here's the thing it's basically doubling
down on its existing business and
and uber eats and and things like that
but like what about the moon shots like
don't you need some long-term projects
that you're
i don't think they're giving up on all
their long-term projects but the really
really crazy ones they
are right and like aurora you know
all right next
elon musk makes two big moves first
to texas he is now a proud texan y'all
um two he uh uh
hold on uh tesla has indicated that
it will sell up to five billion dollars
in additional shares from time to time
and he he's basically being musk i don't
know what to tell you
yeah that's fine so what does he do well
he i think the news is that he moved to
texas
of course he did also that yeah he moved
to texas you know why he moved to texas
because he literally has california
politicians
talking [ __ ] to him on twitter i'd move
too
yesterday i watched an interview he did
with the wall street journal for their
conference
i mean he was coming after the haters
and he was basically like you know what
america gave me an opportunity to
basically they asked him do you think
that
you you're a proud um immigrant
who says uh americo this is the only
country in the world where he
have been he would have been able to
build things that he has built
and he couldn't have done that in any
other country and they said do you think
that still holds true for
in 2020 and he said yes i
think innovation is alive and well and i
still do think that those
opportunities exist facts but he is
moving to texas so i don't know what
that is
um okay calm the meditation
app is raising 75 million dollars at a
two billion dollar valuation my god
hey when you build things people want
you can build great businesses
that is wild it's literally an app
that may helps you meditate do you know
that you could meditate without an
app you can just sit and not like listen
to things yeah but it's hard to sit with
your thoughts
i know but that's the whole point of
meditation no i fall asleep when i die
i mean i need someone talking to me no
god it's sorry but anyway it's good i
like this business i think it's a
fantastic
it's a fantastic business especially at
the time of covid so many people are
freaked out
stressed out anxietied out zoomed
out they need calm i like this let's
roll
cool all right are you ready for ask
lunch money time
yes all right first one chris fettner
i'm gonna record my first interview for
my new podcast this weekend
any tips to being a great interview host
you both are
great examples
what's your advice um a great interview
host
so here's my biggest piece of advice is
um don't go into it blind this is
literally the opposite strategy of what
he does but he's
very very different from me for me
uh i read and listen to everything that
the guest has done in the past
and i try to i know what their talk
track is
i know exactly most people ask the same
questions
find if you know everything they've ever
said and done
you can pick out things that sound
interesting that nobody else followed up
on
and you know what not to ask and try to
veer the conversation in a different way
because like for example if i want to
listen to james clear on habits
he's doing so many interviews at this
point and every single host kind of asks
him the same stuff
i want to ask him something different so
that that's the
not that i'm interviewing james here i
think you are but regardless just
find the things that find the threads
that are interesting to people that
maybe and make them think if you can
make your guests think
and pause and be like oh my god i've
never been asked that before you're
doing a great job
i only have one piece of advice ask a
question then shut up
hey that's my tweet that's it that's the
whole secret just let the guests talk
that's why that's why people are tuning
in they want to hear the guests
so ask them questions and shut up let
them talk
don't interrupt although you have done
some really great podcasts where you and
the guests kind of go back and forth
um there's exceptions to every rule but
mainly i think that's the best piece of
advice i got
jmw if the aliens land will they be
bullish on bitcoin how do you know they
didn't create bitcoin
damn you mean satosh
is an alien satoshi i just shortened
i don't i don't know i can tell you what
they're not going to be interested in
oh look at this shiny rock honestly why
wouldn't they be interested in the wrong
because they can't bring it back how can
they bring bitcoin back to their
country to their planet because it's
easy just put on a little usb
drive and a little wallet and you just
put it in your pocket and you jump back
on the alien craft and we're out
what are we gonna do with the gold the
gold take this heavy ass gold let's put
the heavy ass gold
in their spaceship you guys want to hear
something crazy i'm technically an alien
because i was a naturalized citizen in
this country and i have an
alien number what kind of bs is that
anyway all right we're done here i think
i have an alien
wifi.com see ya
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five so go check them
out there's a link in the description
that you can click on
i'm an investor a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block flies my second favorite thing in
the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to 8.6
interest on an interest bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to 8.6 interest on a deposit in an
interest bearing account go do your own
research
there's risk associated but 8.6 is
pretty compelling
so click on the link in the description
say thanks to the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends